[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur des gones al tv
leçon spécial débutants avec ninon
bonjour nino alors on va voir
aujourd'hui un match fondamental mais
pas facile qui est le match le plus sans
doute le même le élémentaire le plus
difficile qui soit c'est le match fou et
cavaliers contrevenants et c'est très
difficile
ça c'est le sel matin élémentaire cas
parfois les maîtres d'un vieux panneau
faire aller avec comme ça les exemples
c'est vrai qu'il ya des mecs qui redoute
cette finale énigmes et alors pourtant
il faut la connaître
ça peut arriver les pieds alors surtout
peut-être même c'est intéressant pour
comprendre comment fouet cavaliers
interagissent c'est assez difficile mais
en même temps tôt ou tard il faut que
vous sachiez comment faire ça parce
qu'un jour ou rétro avec dopé est un peu
et vous n'arrivez pas faire moitié de
moi je prends donc on vous expliquait
alors on va voir ça va on va voir ça
c'est pas tout à fait facile mais avec
un peu d'entraînement vous pouvez y
arriver
voilà donc on va comprendre surtout
comment cavaliers fou interagissent
alors ce qu'il faut noter avec le
cavalier c'est que quand le canal et sur
blanc contrôle des cases noires alors
que la par exemple on a un fou de cases
blanches dont qui va être toujours plus
intéressant d'avoir le fou le carré sur
la même couleur que le fou pour que les
deux soient complémentaires
le full sur les cases blanches pendant
que lecavalier nuit contrôle des cases
noires comme ça on voit bien que ces
cases là sont interdites aux rois aura
noir et on va voir comment on peut jouer
avec ça alors il faut aussi cédé durable
en le pool calais suffisent pas il faut
que le roy participent
l'idée principale savoir dans quel point
il faut ramener le roi
il va falloir ramener le roi d'air dans
un coin il faut savoir lequel parce
qu'il ya un coup l'on peut pas ma télé
en fait c'est ça oui c'est ça donc
choisissez donc on va expliquer qu'on
fait on peut pas maté si le roi du côté
du coin de la couleur inverse de celle
du fou on peut pas mates et maintenant
on peut pas empêcher le roi noir dit
allez donc ce qu'il faudra faire c'est
forcé le roi noir d'aller de l'autre
côté sur la couleur du four on va voir
ça en contre juste savoir aussi on dit
souvent si c'est vous qui restait donc
dans cette situation avec le roi donc
allez-y dans nos couleurs opposées pour
faire
par recevoir le match je suis en fait il
faut pas non plus court et le
directement le meilleur c'est encore
c'est bien sûr pour que ces dalles au
centre si vous arrivez pestait donc
c'est pas la peine pour tout de suite
dans le coin des couleurs opposées nous
rester dans le centre et tortures aux
deux adversaires
je suis apprécié l'art et vous rend
minus que le coin voilà vous allez
plutôt choisir l'autre coin mais voilà
si vous êtes en défense donc il faut
apprendre il faut aller dans le coin de
la couleur aux causes est opposé à ce
qu'il faut et à savoir si vous
perdez pas où vous gagnez pas dans 53 52
50 l'adversaire paraît que la minul
c'est à dire c'est qu'ils restent avec
le roi il a droit d'arrêter la minul a
pas cinquante coups si vous jouez très
bien phu et cavaliers normalement à
moins de 40 coups je crois qu'il faut 35
ou froid dans la pierre des positions
pour mater dont vous allez voir comment
on peut y arriver alors c'est simple il
faudra d'abord ramener le roi vers le
centre toujours très important il faut
s'aider des autres pièces donc déjà on
ramène le cavalier on les met en quatre
ici protéger regardez on n'a pas peur on
met le cavalier sur une case blanche
protégé par le fou on n'a pas peur c'est
une question de peur mais on contrôle
comme ça des cases noires donc on va
céder de ce contrôle des classements
avec laurent blanc et qui vont être
complémentaire de celle du fou pour
l'instant si on n'approche pas l'endroit
pour ça on voit pas la force
forcément donc là on avance petit à
petit voilà le roi noir est obligé
maintenant de bouger dr kaba voilà on se
rapproche du centre au f4 voilà et voilà
on prend le centre donc à savoir là où
montre pratiquement les meilleures cotes
de défense pas pratiquement même célèbre
conte défense pour le noir vous avez
remarqué le roi restant le centre pour
l'instant on n'a pas à on n'est pas
parti directement vers les places
étaient favorables pour les noirs donc
déjà il faut caveau si c'est votre
adversaire qui reste de l'europe qu'elle
joue si bien sinon vous allez gagner
mais plus facilement que ça donc il faut
absolument maintenant gagner des cases
noires parce que là si le roi blanc ne
peut contrôler qu'une casement ainsi
donc pour l'un c'est que si le roi reste
ici on va pas y arriver donc il faut il
faut contrôler des cases alors on bouge
le cavalier un échec
voilà et on fait un échec ici alors
regardez comme le fou ici mais dans
contre la case blanche et le cavalier
lui la case noire avec les virois donc
le renoir est obligé de partir donc par
exemple il d'un petit reste au contact
du centre f5 et là regardez donc il
pourra pas venir ici on sera bien
content s'il vient là puisqu'on pourra
gagner du terrain avec le roi donc on
jauge
beaucoup d'attentes des 5 il faut que le
roi bouge donc par exemple projet 4
sinon ben on aurait joué façon dans tous
les cas jouer re 4 on croit g4 on joue
trois quatre ou cinq ici on n'a pas peur
d'aller voir là puisque la regarder le
parma s'échapper parce qu'on a peur
toujours que le roi s'échappe ne peut
pas s'échapper là parce qu'on regardait
ce cavalier commises superbe puisqu'ils
contrôlent les cases noires et le faux
et le fou regarde et toujours pareil les
cases blanches donc toutes ces cases
bardet le roi blanc déjà s'il vient par
la passe s'il vient par ici il se bloque
lui-même en fait il suffit d'amener
laurent et il est déjà sur la bande dans
le réseau de maths il est déjà dans le
raisonnement donc ça va aller très vite
donc il va changer c'est pourquoi parce
qu'il se rapproche du bon coin pour lui
c'est là que ça va être plus dur de le
mater puisqu'on peut pas le mat et là
ils font dans la menée sur un autre coin
mais c'est pas grave d'abord on essayé
de l'amener sur la bande en fait elle a
besoin on verra que c'est facile facile
facile alors que c'est faisable
alors après dans une autre alors faut
être trois pour coiffer 3b parce qu'on
commence à empêcher la can g4 donc il
peut déjà y peut plus revenir
ensuite il va falloir empêcher contrôler
des cases noires donc ça va falloir
ramener le cavalier on croise les six on
ramène le cavalier par exemple angers 3
1 on aurait pu venir
si d'ici là mais non c'est pareil roy
chez 5 et là hop kb24 regarde et hop on
contrôle donc ici des cases noires et
avec le fou des cases blanches
donc si le roi bien là mais il sera
prisonnier d'une
ici d'une variété j'ai chaque fois le
roi recule encore à avoir que vous aussi
vous rapprocher notre roi de cela qu'on
prêterait si la chanson la cie boujenah
on suit avec le roi blanc et ça va être
facile alors donc il essaie de rester au
contact le plus possible et d'éviter
d'aller à la bande et on va voir que
c'est on va pouvoir le sens et voilà le
coin c'est donc ici bon une technique on
joue cavalier des 6es ce roi g5 up ont
fait cavaliers recettes on contrôle la
case noire on n'a pas peur que leurs
ouailles là puisqu'on va le coincer
direct comme son balcon c'est donc faux
qui remonte et là haut poursuit avec le
roi le cavalier contraire regardez comme
il peut pas sortir toujours pareil dès
que le cavalier et sur blanc il contrôle
les cases et troisième temps qu'on voit
les contrôler et il peut pas sortir tout
contrôler il voit bien qu'il est il est
coincé au g7 et maintenant évidemment
faux 4 regardez toujours pareil
contrôler la case noire qui va bien être
obligé d'aller à la bande voilà ça y est
lié y'a plus qu'à fermer la boîte
voilà c'est fait il est alors il est à
la bande le roi les boissons de position
il est du mauvais côté
on peut pas le maté ici va falloir la
vie de l'autre côté et c'est là c'est là
qu'en fait la vraie manoeuvre en fait on
va dire on va commencer donc donc 16 il
faut pas considérer d'alassaï fn et
peut-être même juste la deuxième partie
qui commence par ces deux positions clés
comme celle ci et il faut vous sachiez
comment maîtriser ça mais c'est déjà une
réussite si vous ramenez bien sûr le roi
d'ici mai
parfois j'ai déjà vu le parti ou le roi
s'échappe d'ici aussi parce qu'on va
voir plus tard il ya un coût très
important on voir avec le fou plus tard
au trinquet comment montrer cette
situation va relancer le noir et c'est
de garder le contact vers le leinster g8
ont fait un coude attentes puisque l'on
peut pas faire grand chose
on attend qu'ils veulent un but et là
regardez la manoeuvre c'est de jouer
fourchette voilà ça y est on l'empêchent
de venir dans l'automobile d'aller dans
la gauche donc oui il reste qu'à une
série quasi ci avait pour le roi donc la
yam en hongrie vous notez bien le roi
face aux cavaliers le cavaly contrôler
les cases noires et avec le fou up
contre la case blanche donc on le pousse
l'autre côté alors là le coup pour le
roi c'est devenir la pila attention on
peut avoir peur puisque le roi risquent
de s'échapper on ne sait pas où mais en
fait ils s'échappent jamais regarder là
où la manoeuvre qu'il faut connaître
celle ci à ce moment là cavalier ou 5
voilà on contrôle à la case ici et
l'idée c'est qu'on veut mettre le cap
sur cette case fait le cavalier fait une
soeur d'être rentable et on peut même
pas être destinée se re comme ça bien
sûr le cavalier ce qu'il veut faire
regarder le passé d'une thèse blanche
ici revenir là et un contrat et après
voir ici et là c'est le meneur des
cavaliers qui sera soutenue par le roi
vous allez voir le roi sur le cavalier
on contrôle d'abord cette case mans puis
à prendre contre alors on contrôlera
celle-ci regarder et après une fois
qu'on sera là on contrôlera celle là
donc petit à petit le roi a décalé
heures le coin quand on a ramené on va
le pousser par là petit à petit on va
les pousser vers la gauche surtout donc
arrêté les sept grandes avenues pour ça
aide bien parce qu'elle est on est
parfois perdus comme ça sans fléchir la
partie traitée les sept manières de
table que ça va vous aider oui ça c'est
très important cette pub de calais et
donc l'amener vers la couleur du fou un
très important
alors vous me conseillez de 37 à 45
alors là il ya deux il ya de défense
pour les noirs soit on essaie de
s'échapper qui est la plus technique on
le verra tout à l'heure la plus simple
pour l'épauler blanc c'est quand le roi
essaie quand même de se rapprocher mais
on va voir c'est très facile maintenant
que le cavalier là puisqu'on il suffit
de faire un échec
alors on fait la manoeuvre combien de
nos cités c'est tout à fait là
en gros si on enlève ce qu'on a vu là ce
qu'on vient juste de voir la pression on
en attaque le fou empêche le roi noir
d'aller à droite donc il est obligé donc
après on va faire toujours pareil on va
faire ça donc c'est facile
regardez la manoeuvre dont 3,8
maintenant ramène le roi et on va
essayer peut plus venir ici car les
contrôles donc obligés d'aller en des 8
et là c'est le foot étant lui enfin si
d'abord il faut bien sûr qu'elle sort
voilà on n'empêche qu'ils soient et s'il
revient c'est le fou maintenant c'est le
fou qui entrent dans le jeu
voilà ce roi ici on fait un coude
attentes donc ce qu'il fait le roi 7e
place avec le kawaï et je suis le roi
noir vers la gauche et c'est le fou qui
fait ici le travail de nuit pas n'est
pas fait les séries s'échapper donc ici
et coup d'attendre
voilà et on fait la même manoeuvre
convient de voir ont remis le cavalier
ici mes lauriers web on s'approche
maintenant dangereusement de la fin roy
ci reviendra donc à gauche silva à
droite c'est facile suffit sur henri
leroy silva ici on fait échec
voilà et on suit avec le roi
tranquillement et suroît but 8
eh bien on suit est à prévoir si vite
c'est d'ailleurs refait la manoeuvre
avec le fou on le voit ainsi obligés
d'aller à gauche evra ça y est ils
étaient dans une petite boîte de deux
cases contrôlée par le fou tjs à gagner
juste il faut surtout pas vous évitez le
pas échappé aussi le roi d'ici sa
catastrophique parce que c'est
pratiquement déjà gagné alors on va voir
c'est facile alors par exemple cavale et
c5
enfin parce qu'on veut maintenant
cliquer dans la boîte un oui c'est pas
c'est pas le confort c'est forcément
c'est juste une manière de gagner par
exemple 8 l'on peut faire par exemple
pouces et 8 ont agressé un des plus
simples ce n'est plus un produit 8
on vient à 6 voyez comme ça le roi est
vraiment définitivement fermé si vous ne
bougez plus votre roi fou même si quand
il était très loin voilà c'est fait
créer cette boîte après vous rapprocher
le cavalier ou fait de maths voilà on ne
fait pas la faute de venir en dix-sept
ce serait pas on attend on fait d'abord
échec au roi et suroît b8 maintenant on
fait maths
voyez donc là on est dans le bon coin il
ya mat il n'y a pas de problème alors
simple trop simple alors rappelez vous
ce qu'on vous a dit c'était la plus
simple celle là après un peu plus
compliqué mais ces pourvoyeurs c'est pas
si compliqué que ça ça si on avait dit
si revient vers là c'est facile il
suffit de faire échec et ont fait la
manoeuvre
qu'on a cité ni tac tac tac si le roi
essaie de s'échapper maintenant roi ici
mais vous allez voir qu'en fait ils
s'échappent pas vraiment ils n'arrivent
pas à s'échapper parce que fo et
cavaliers sont très bien armée pour
l'empêcher alors il suffit dans ce
cas-là de rapprocher le roi pour
l'instant c'est normal non c'est normal
et le roi de toujours sous suivre comme
ça et on contrôle la classe 17 parce
qu'on veut l'amener là le cavalier quoi
qu'il arrive
oui oui on attention soit dire mais il
va il va s'échapper oui mais il va pas
vraiment s'échapper regardez donc garder
comme sémalens calais 17 et regardez
déjà pouf pouf ces deux cases très
importante contrôlée par cas les
regarder je veux qu'on me dire ça c'est
une troisième position clairement
considéré comme ça dans une oeuvre dans
le manuel de l'échec comme troisième
position clef à retenir absolument ces
coups là comment vous entré juste
maintenant alors ils étaient 17 et s'est
vidé on va montrer alors regardez sur
roissy centre droit bessette c'était
pareil là on a vraiment l'impression le
roi à saillé est complètement échappé
mais pas de tout en fait pas du tout
regardé brad est bon il est coincé
évidemment par le roi blanc aussi si
tout ça c'est tout ça est très bien
contrôlés regardez il suffit de les
empêcher de partir la regarder ça c'est
quoi ce des cases blanches même s'il
était venu en bessette c'était pareil on
joue le même coup regardez food et 3 et
voilà ça y est dans la boîte
regardez bien regardez comme c'est clair
cases noires ici case blanche
de ce côté il est dans la boîte ne pas
sortir d'ici à cause du roi blanc qui
contrôle tout il est bien dans une boîte
elle était internée bon là il est
enfermé
donc ils descendent donc par exemple
s'il vient c'est cette dîme comment on
fait pour protéger progresser c'est
simple on fout on peut ramener le
foulard soit en bessin que c'est pareil
soit plutôt sur au 400 m haies dames
c'est la même chose regardez toujours
pareil les quinze mois et maintenant les
cases blanches
on est comme ces bouts comme ces deux
pièces sont superbes et il est obligé de
revenir sur la bande par exemple ans et
8 et maintenant on ferme la boîte avec
le roi mais voilà c'est fini ils
s'arrêteront exactement dans les même
possible voilà on se retrouve la même
position de thaler donc il peut pas
vraiment s'échapper c'était une illusion
en fait on croit des huit ans le bloc
par le fou pour l'obliger d'aléas
auch il va ensuite hélas toujours cette
manoeuvre de cavaliers la même regardez
donc s'il revient à droite ont fait
échec et silva à gauche
eh bien on ramène le roi tout simplement
et après 3,8
car elle est belle cette voie là ça y
est il peut pas sortir des 8,3 b6 suroît
c8 fouiller chaque fois trois ans b 8
ordina manoeuvre fou aussi sont beaucoup
d'attentes roi 8 qu'avait laissé cinq
rois b8 c'est un autre match on en a vu
un tas l'heure c'est le même match ici
il est toujours dans la boîte aux le fou
le day 3 6 est ici est sûre donc ici car
il y a 6 échecs ont obligés à 8 et voyez
pourquoi c'est le bon coup parce que
c'est le bon coin de cavaliers protège
ici et maintenant on peut faire échec et
mat l'autre côté vous pourrez vérifier
que l'on peut pas c'est bizarre mais
c'est comme ça voilà vous finalement
c'est pas si compliqué que ça si on
arrive à bien visualiser le fait que
cavalier d'eau toujours être sur la case
du fou pour contrôler 15 mois donc s'il
quitte une case si on veut gagner des
cases il faut jouer un deux coups avec
lecavalier
alors si on l'enlève c'est bien pour le
remettre tout de suite il faut pas que
laurent blanc s'échappe non plus du roi
noir il faut qu'il reste au contact et
en général ils le roi blanc est là pour
protéger le cavalier et gagner des 15
avec lui en cédant donc dû vous voyez
donc les trois pièces sont essentiels
pour mater donc retenir comment disait
j'ai désiré il ya trois étapes quand
même d'abord on fait reculer le roi qui
est dans le centre et ça vous voyez ça
se passe assez naturellement
pratiquement tous les coups que vous
faites plus tard donc ça ça se
facilement il n'y a pas grand chose à
apprendre vous seront placés les pièces
dans le centre et ça se passe
naturellement par contre une fois donc
le roi c'est rétro impôts déjà sur 8e ou
etc la retenir donc sept mineurs d'afw
l'appel le cavalier bleu ça fait et une
position vraiment très très important
des positions clés où j'ai vu donc
souffrir certains de mettre un
chronomètre qui ont oublié cette règle
d'or c'est avec le fou peut-être
mon père est médecin position dernière
fois pour vous faire répéter ou c'était
d'être voilà ici où elle a donc sur quoi
vous faites en fait justement qu'en ldc
d'ailleurs peut-être pour montrer donc
ici vous n'êtes pas peur vous être
tranquille vous laisser le roi sur ces 7
par exemple et vous faites juste comme
les 17 et en sachant que vous avez un
coup tranquille après foot est roi qui
bloquent totalement la boîte donc c'est
fou des trois parfois s'il y avait une
pression de temps et si on n'a pas
forcément dans la tête ce coup j'ai vu
vraiment beaucoup de joueurs qui ont
raté cette occasion les après le roi qui
est sorti la partie dure plus longtemps
parfois il nous pourrait aussi à gagner
parce que conviendrait les 50 min voilà
un coup oui alors regardez la manoeuvre
rappelez vous cette manière de callian
wma et c'est un vrai w1
voilà donc on part en général du mauvais
coin ambulance il va directement dans
leboncoin son quizz et sylvana mauvais
quoi il faut le forcer à lui notre côté
et voilà la manoeuvre donc on n'hésite
pas sur wuala up sa cavale et l'acquis
des jalles empêche de sortir en 17 et
silva la up
on le suit avec le roi et on ferme la
boîte avec lecavalier on décèle toujours
on n'a pas peur ambiante 17 il peut pas
s'échapper par des poufs ronds pour
s'entraîner en nous ce qu'on conseille
sur canal tv il ya des logiciels mais
non des chèques partout il y en a sur le
net qui sont gratuits évidemment vous
pouvez mettre cette position et
entraînez-vous contre l'ordinateur vous
allez voir que même lui il peut pas
résister il ya mc forcés dont ils
saluent une bonne méthode
moi je me rappelle je vais m'entraîner
même tout seul comme ça je sais pas
comment décrire mais en fait je me suis
même pas vu le taux de sel et j'ai vu
toutes celles sur l'échiquier comme ça
c'était un projet magie pour quelqu'un
qui joue pas être un peu fou mais je me
suis bien entraîné il faut s'entraîner
c'est comme faire des exercices
parce que
j'ai pas dire perdre rapidement j'avais
une fois parti où il me restait une
minute exactement le roi était toujours
dans le centre je n'étais pas très
expérimenté à cette époque là et j'ai
pas près aussi gagné dans une minute
donc je suis tombé donc c'était passer
le temps la partie s'est terminée le nul
et après ils étaient en colère donc
contre moi pourquoi j'ai pas fais maths
et je me suis entraîné tout seul sur le
chéquier et en même temps je me suis mis
dans pendule pour me mettre la pression
comme cetelem répartie donc je vais me
tester si j'arriverai faire maintenant
le trans compte par exemple
et j'irai aussi dans vingt secondes
quand secondes donc voilà vous pouvez
faire ça aussi si vous n'avez pas de
logiciel d'échec chez vous vous pouvez
parfaitement mettre aussi sur ma chique
est tout simplement vous et toutes
celles avec un ami et voilà donc c'est
important parce que ça permet aussi
c'est peut-être pas une finale que vous
verrez souvent c'est très rare mais ça
vous permet de bien comprendre comment
marche fouilles cavaliers donner des
idées aux gens c'est une belle exercice
pour voir comment ça se combinent
commencent à se complètent cette pièce
tout à fait merci nino c'était la
plaisir vous montrer tout ça tant
qu'homme et on vous donne rendez-vous à
bientôt sur son terrain la tv pour
d'autres jeux le son au revoir
[Musique]